you spoken honestly about the
possibility of war between us and China
in the long term if no diplomatic
solution is found for example on the
question of Taiwan and one China policy
right how do we avoid the trajectory
where these two superpowers
Clash well it's it's worth reading that
book on the the difficult to pronounce
through CAD trap I believe it's called I
love war history I like inside out and
backwards um there hardly a battle I
haven't read read
about and and trying to figure out like
what what really was the cause of
victory in any particular case as
opposed to what one side or another
claimed the reason both the Victory and
what sparked the war and yeah yeah the
whole thing yeah so that Athens and
Sparta it's classic case the thing about
the Greeks they really wrote down a lot
of stuff they loved writing um you know
there are lots of interesting things
that happened in many parts of the world
but they people didn't write down so we
don't know what happened happened or
they didn't really write
with in detail they just would say like
we went we had a battle and we won and
like what can you add a bit more um the
the the Greeks they really wrote a
lot they were very articulate on they
just love writing so and we have a bunch
of that writing that's preserved so we
know what led up to the pipian war
between um the spot and Athenian
Alliance um and uh
we we know that they they for quite they
they saw it
coming I mean the Spartans didn't right
they they also weren't very Bose by
their nature but they did right but they
weren't very B they were tur uh but the
the Athenians and the other Greeks were
Ro a line and they were
like um and spot was really kind of like
the leader of of Greece um but but
Athens grew stronger and stronger with
each passing
year and um and and everyone's like well
that's inevitable that there's going to
be a clash between Athens and
Sparta uh well how do we avoid that and
they couldn't they couldn't they
actually they saw it coming and they
still could not avoid
it so you know at some point if there's
if if
one uh group one civilization or or
country or whatever
um exceeds another sort of like if you
know the United States has been the
biggest kill on the Block
for since I think around 1890 from an
economic standpoint so the United States
has been the economic most powerful
economic engine in the world longer than
anyone's been
alive
um and the foundation of war is
economics
so now we have a situation in the case
of china where the uh um the economy is
likely to be two perhaps three times
larger than that of the US so imagine
you're the biggest kid on the Block for
as long as anyone can remember and
suddenly a kid comes along who's twice
your
size so we see it coming yeah how is it
possible to stop is there some let me
throw something out there just
intermixing of cultures understanding
there does seem to be a giant cultural
Gap in understanding of each other
and you're an interesting case study
because you are an American obviously
you've done a lot
of uh incredible manufacturer here in
the United States but you also work with
China I've spent a lot of time in China
and met with the leadership many times
maybe a good question to ask is what are
some things about China that people
don't understand positive just in the
culture what's some interesting things
that you've learned about the
Chinese well uh the the sheer number of
really smart hardworking people in China
is um incredible uh there are really you
say like how many smart hardworking
people are there in China there's far
more of them there than there are here I
think in my in my opinion
um the uh and they've got a lot of
energy
so I mean the architecture in China
that's in recent years is far more
impressive than the US I mean the the
train stations the buildings the
highspeed rail everything it's
um really far more impressive than what
we have in the US I I mean I recommend
somebody just go to Shanghai and
Beijing look at the buildings and go to
you know take the train from Beijing to
Shion where you have the Terracotta
Warriors um China's got incredible
history very long history and um you
know I think arguably the in terms of
the use of language from from a written
standpoint um sort of one of one of the
oldest Perhaps Perhaps the oldest
written language and and then China
people did write things down
so um now China um historically has
always been with rare exception been
internally focused um they've not been
inquisitive uh they've they' fought each
other there been many many Civil Wars um
in the Three Kingdoms War I believe they
lost about 70% of the
population
so so the they've had brutal internal
Wars like civil wars that make the US
Civil War
look small by
comparison
um so I think it's important to
appreciate that China is not
monolithic um we sort of think of like
China as the sort of one entity well off
one mind and this is definitely not the
case um from what I've seen and I think
most people who understand China would
agree people in China think about China
10 times more than they think about
anything outside of China so it's like
90% of their consideration is uh you
know are is is internal well isn't that
a really positive thing when you're
talking about the collaboration and a
future peace between superpowers when
you're inward face which is like
focusing on improving yourself versus
focusing on yeah uh quote unquote
improving others through military might
the good news the history of China
suggests that China is not inquisitive
meaning they're not going to go out and
invade a whole bunch of countries um now
they do feel very strongly you know so
that's that's good I mean because a lot
of lot of very powerful countries have
been inquisitive um the US is one of the
also one of the rare cases that has not
been inquisitive like after World War II
the us could have basically taken over
the world and any country like we got
nukes nobody else got nukes we don't
even have to lose
soldiers uh which country do you want MH
and the United States could have taken
over everything oh at will and it didn't
um and the United States actually helped
rebuild countries so it helped rebuild
Europe you it helped rebuild Japan um
this is very unusual behavior almost
unprecedented
um
you know the US did conspicuous acts of
kindness like the Berlin
airlift you
know
um and and I think you know it's always
like well America's done bad things well
of course America's done bad things but
one needs to look at the the whole track
record um and and just
generally you know one one sort of test
would be how do you treat your prisoners
of War mhm or let's say
um you know no offense to the Russians
but let's say you're in Germany it's
1945 you got the Russian army coming on
one side you got the French British and
American armies coming on the other side
who would you like to be to surrender to
like no country is like morally perfect
but I recommend uh being a PW with the
Americans that would be my choice very
strongly in the full menu of very much
so and in fact Von Brown um yeah took
you know smallart guy uh was like we've
got to be captured by the Americans
yeah and uh in fact the SS was under
orders to execute B Brown and all of the
uh German rocket Engineers uh and they
narrowly escaped their SSI they said
they were going out for a walk in the
woods they left in the middle of winter
with no coats
uh and ran like and with no food no coat
no water and just ran like hell uh and
ran West um and by Sher like they I
think his brother found like a a bicycle
or something and um and then just cycled
W as fast as he couldn't found found a
US
Patrol um so anyway that's that's one
that's one way you can
tell morality is who who where do you
want to be a
PW it's not fun anywhere but some place
are much worse than others
so um anyway so so so like America has
been uh while far from perfect uh
generally a benevolent Force um and uh
we should always be self-critical and uh
would try to be better um but um anyone
with half a bra knows that so so I think
there are in this way China and uh the
United States are similar NE neither
country has been
inquisitive um in a significant way so
that's like a you know a shared
principle I guess um now now China does
feel very strongly about
Taiwan they've been very clear about
that for a long time um you know from
their standpoint it's it's it would be
like one of the states is is is you know
not there like like Hawaii or something
like that but but more significant than
Hawaii you know um
and Hawaii is pretty significant for us
so um they view it as as really
the that there's a fundamental part of
China the island of fosa not not Taiwan
that is um not part of China but should
be uh and the only reason it hasn't been
is because of the US Pacific
Fleet and as their economic power grows
and as their military power
grows the thing that they are clearly
saying
uh is their interest will you know
clearly be
materialized
yes China has been very clear that um
they will incorporate Taiwan uh
peacefully or um militarily but that
they will incorporate it from their
standpoint is 100%
likely you know something you said about
conspicuous acts of kindness as a
geopolitical policy
it almost seems
naive but I'd venture to say that this
is probably the path forward how you
avoid most wars just as you say it it
sounds naive but it's kind of
brilliant if you believe in the goodness
of underlying most of human nature it
just seems like conspicuous acts of
kindness can uh reverberate through the
populace of the countries
involved yeah well and deescalate
absolutely so after World War One the
the they made a big mistake you know
they basically tried to lump all the
blame on Germany um and
um and and you know settled Germany with
uh impossible
reparations um and you know really there
was a lot of there was a fair about a
blame to um go around for World War I um
but they they try to you know put it all
in Germany
um and uh that was that that laid the
seeds for World War
II uh
so that's a lot of people well not just
Hitler a lot of people felt wronged um
and they wanted
Vengeance and they got it people don't
forget yeah you you you kill
somebody's father mother son daughter
they not going to forget it they will
want Vengeance um so after World War II
they're like well the Treaty of usai was
a huge mistake um in world world
one and um so this time instead
of
uh you know crushing the losers we're
we're actually going to help them
with the Marshall Plan and we're going
to help re reu Germany we're going to
help rebuild or you know Austria and the
other you know Italy and whatnot
so
um that was the right move there's uh it
does feel like there's a profound
truth to uh conspicuous acts of kind as
being an antidote to
this something wased off the the cycle
of reciprocal
violence something will stop it or it
will you know it'll it'll it'll never
stop
just eye for an eye tooth for a tooth
limb for a limb life for a life forever
and
ever